hey youtubers is Charlie so HBO has
finally confirmed what the final season
of Game of Thrones is going to be good
news bad news situation so bad news
first there's only going to be eight
seasons but the good news is is that
they are talking about a spinoff so
here's a breakdown so if you didn't know
the TCA Zoar basically we're like a
bunch of television critics learn about
Network's new series each on a different
day so like HBO just had their day today
talking about all the series that are
coming this fall like Westworld for
instance they have course said a few
things about Game of Thrones even though
they just had a big comic-con panel so
they confirm that there would be a short
and run for the final seasons and they
did officially confirm this season eight
will be the last season so that does
sound very sad but then as if to take
that back a little bit they did say that
they were talking about a spin-off but
that any spin-off that they did would
have to make sense creatively so that's
actually a big change from the last time
they had a big panel like this they they
typically do the TCAs twice a year the
last time they did it before season six
a tear they said that they had not had
any material discussions about spin-offs
yet so that happened sometime in the
last couple of months and everybody has
probably heard with george RR martin has
said about spin-offs but all circle back
around for that just to talk about the
final season so as much of a bummer as
it is they basically have about 15 hours
of television that they said that they
could tell they've said seven episodes
for next season and what will probably
end up happening is is previously the
big rumor was is that season eight would
be six episodes but now a lot of people
are believing that the final season will
be seven episodes either way it'll be
shorter than the normal ten but anytime
someone tells you that you're getting an
extra episode that you did not think
that you were going to get you always
get it cited in speaking of more episode
so if you didn't notice this season
there were a couple episodes that were
way longer than the normal run time so
normal episodes are somewhere just like
a little over 50 minutes long but there
were a couple episodes that were almost
like 60 some that were just a little bit
longer than that so it's probably going
to happen is is because they are
shortening the episode run they'll just
make each episode just a little bit
longer so instead of in season seven of
you getting like seven individual
episodes you're almost getting like
eight or nine or even ten episodes
crammed into seven episodes so you're
still getting the same amount of content
it's the same thing with
Netflix series like they might only do
13 episodes per season but each episode
is 10 to 12 minutes longer than like a
normal Network TV episode which is
typically like 42 minutes you wind up
getting way more content than just each
of those individual episodes would
normally be so do not freak out about
there being less Game of Thrones
episodes and yes I totally believe that
they will eventually make a spin-off
series that doesn't mean it'll happen
right after Game of Thrones ends its run
if it is or even if they're close they
will probably announce that is they're
getting ready to air the final season
like oh you know we know the final
seasons coming up but we also have this
in our back pocket we also have all
these other dragons that we're going to
release so if you haven't seen any of
the other spin-off videos that I've done
George R Martin himself has said that
Dunkin egg is probably the leading
candidate like that would be the best
place for them to go next in the funny
thing you know behind the scenes HBO
bought the rights to do Game of Thrones
the TV series but they only bought the
rights to the Maine Song of Ice and Fire
novels they did not buy the rights to
the Dunkin egg story so they'd actually
have to pony up more money to George or
Martin to get that which I don't think
that they would have any problem doing
they would definitely be down for that
so if they opted to not go with the
Dunkin egg series they could totally do
a prequel series that covers the history
of the Targaryen family george RR martin
has even said that after he's done with
the Song of Ice and Fire novels after
he's done with novel number seven
remember he's finishing six now there's
one more book after that after he
finishes that what he wants to do is
write a book called fire in blood and
it'd basically be the complete history
of the Targaryen family it'd be like a
world history told from the perspective
of different generations of Targaryen
families going all the way back to
ancient Valyria up through Daenerys so
he will be treading over some story that
he's done before but it'll be from a
completely different perspective like
he's written stories about Aegon the
conquerer he appears in the world of Ice
and Fire novel but the way that book is
written it's as if a maester is reading
it out loud it's written in third person
so it's a little different than the POV
chapters that you see in the main Song
of Ice and Fire novels so option 3 is to
do the dance of the Dragons which is
another big Targaryen Civil War one of
the many Targaryen Civil Wars that's
happened but they would definitely have
to write more material they're already
three novellas for the dunk and egg
series there's far less material that
George R Martin has written for the
dance of the dragons but for those of
you
asking about Robert's rebellion like
wouldn't it be amazing to see a Robert's
rebellion prequel HBO already owns the
rights to make that TV show they
wouldn't have to pay extra money for it
but the problem is is that they're kind
of telling that story in flashbacks on
the current show and I think that any
spin-off show that they end up doing
will be a bunch of different characters
there might be a little overlap because
like the three-eyed Raven for instance
he's been alive for about 200 years so
if you went back and did the dance of
the Dragons he'd still be a young man at
that time so there'd be a little overlap
but it wouldn't be the exact same group
of characters every single week so just
let me know in the comments what do you
think the spin-off is going to be and
when do you think that it's going to
drop do you think that they would wait
till right after Game of Thrones ends
its run or do you think there'd be like
a period of a year or two break while
they're still developing the spin-off
like they finish the game of Thrones run
and they don't have anything in
development or waiting like they have to
wait a couple years to get it going but
when you think about Game of Thrones
eighth season run think about the
hundreds of millions of dollars they've
spent on costumes on props they could
use that for another Game of Thrones
series even if it's set in the past they
just like they have all this stuff that
they could use for another TV series
that they wouldn't have to spend another
hundred million dollars making but the
two things that I think that will be
critical to any spin-off is that one
there would be dragons and two we would
be able to see the White Walkers in some
way like the magic that's happening
north of the wall even if it's vastly
different than from what's happening
right now they would need to be some
great Titanic threat and I just feel
like there would have to be dragons like
who wants to watch a Game of Thrones
series where there's no dragons and
there's no supernatural threat so let me
know in the comments what is your pick
for the Game of Thrones spin-off series
and I'll also say congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Andrew yeah
you win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details and I almost forgot if you guys
didn't know Game of Thrones Season 7
unofficially confirmed to premiere
summer of 2017 but I'm thinking that
probably means early June so it just
several weeks after it would normally
premiere each year well you guys wait
for me to post my next video you can
click here for my breakdown of the
season 7 teaser trailer and you can
click here for all my marvel trailers
from Comic Con thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you